qui est pour qui est contre la science
est levée
la séance est levée
la séance la séance et levée
bonjour
Eric Peugeot député d'Antibes et la 7e
circonscription des Alpes-Maritimes j'ai
été désigné rapporteur pour avis des
crédits de la sécurité civile et donc je
vais travailler sur les moyens accordés
à nos pompiers dans le cas de la
prévention et de la lutte contre les
incendies les feux de forêt je vous
amène d'abord à la rencontre des
pompiers du 10-06 et ensuite on ira sur
le terrain
une mission décidé au début de l'été
juste avant que la France ne brûle
65000 hectares et des incendies Records
et des régions jusque là jamais touchées
alors le rapport est attendu par chance
la circonscription des riches n'a pas
connu de grands feux sans doute grâce au
moyen déployés par le Département c'est
ce que veut comprendre le député
rendez-vous est pris sur la base des
hélicoptères bombardiers d'eau de
Valbonne
et bonjour l'idée c'est de venir voir
comment on intervient ici pour voir
derrière comment on pourrait le
modéliser sur d'autres départements sur
d'autres disques
tout l'été en plus des Canadairs de
l'État les pompiers des Alpes-Maritimes
ont investi dans trois hélicoptères ils
sont les seuls à bénéficier d'une telle
flotte les trois appareils ont permis de
maîtriser rapidement les 24 départs de
feu de l'été
on peut larguer près de 1500 litres
d'eau avec un kit de sous donc on a une
trace de largage qui est aussi beaucoup
plus efficace
[Musique]
une fois qu'ils ont fait un premier
dragage sur le feu ils vont rechercher
de l'eau sur le premier plan d'eau et si
les plans d'eau sont pas suffisants on
équipe le terrain de citerne
et il largue de l'eau toutes les 10
minutes bien plus rapidement qu'un
Canadair on évite les fameux
photographes et les fameux méga feu que
dont tout le monde parle son un maximum
de chances de les éviter tous les feux
qu'on était avant on en fera pas des
mégafeu donc il faut se donner un
maximum de chance d'autant plus que
cette première c'est là où on est
efficace le feu et la partie beaucoup de
puissance beaucoup d'ampleur mais très
efficace
très efficace et là l'hélico ça reste
l'outil majeur d'intervention
parce que c'est celui qui va intervenir
le plus rapidement c'est le premier le
premier verbaux mais c'est lui qui va la
porter l'hélicoptère c'est dix minutes
et ces hélicos ces échos qui ont été
conçus pour la défense feu de forêt ou
c'est des échos qui ont été adaptés
adaptés
[Musique]
le progrès majeur qui a été fait au
niveau des services d'incendie des 30
dernières années s'il arrivait des
écouteurs
Bruno qui nous ont fait faire un bon un
grand bon sur l'efficacité de la lutte
si un jour des moyens à mettre faut
surtout les mettre là s'il fallait faire
un choix financier qu'il faut le faire
un modèle qui a un coup
2,3 millions d'euros pour la location
chaque été de ces hélicoptères mais il a
convaincu le député là on est en plein
dans le travail parlementaire
c'est-à-dire d'échanger avec un
contrôleur général d'un disque qui est
parmi les plus les plus puissants de
France qui nous expliquent le sujet la
thématique et comme je vous disais moi
par rapport aux a priori que j'avais il
y a quelques mois en arrière j'ai
considérablement évolué j'ai découvert
la doctrine du vite et forte m'a
expliqué que le contrôleur général dièse
aujourd'hui je m'aperçois que c'est ce
modèle qu'il faut qu'on modélise
ailleurs en France dans d'autres
départements et dans d'autres disques et
peut-être avec l'été qu'on vient de voir
peut-être qu'on aurait évité des
catastrophes ou des feux beaucoup plus
importants qui ont mobilisé des moyens
humains des moyens financiers des moyens
matériels et des vies aussi si on avait
eu cette capacité d'intervention massive
et directe
direction le centre des opérations de
secours pour comprendre comment sont
déployés ces moyens
il faut savoir qu'ils sont en plein
travail c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont
irrécupérables des appels ils sont en
train de traiter des appels il s'appelle
comment ce logis de Saint-Claude madame
si c'est la salle ou avec tous les 18 du
corps départemental c'est à partir de là
que tous les secours sont déclenchés
pour céder les pompiers s'appuient sur
des technologies comme le drone
il est monté tout seul tranquillement il
part à droite alors là vous voyez qu'il
y a aucun accès et là on est les portes
du personnel qui viennent avec des
tuyaux de l'eau
sur là ça n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'on
voit en Gironde ou dans les Landes
que vous expliquez là on est dans le
massivement et vite vite et massivement
intervenir vite massivement là il faut
envoyer le paquet d'entrée pour pas
qu'il devienne important après un feu
lorsqu'il est vraiment important
parce que les nouvelles technologies que
ce soit drone images en 3D ça a
considérablement amélioré le traitement
de le traitement de d'intervention c'est
des outils d'aide à la décision qui nous
permettent d'aller plus vite et
d'ajuster au plus vite
depuis quelques mois les pompiers des
Alpes-Maritimes sont aussi les premiers
à être équipés d'un logiciel qui prend
la main sur la caméra du téléphone de
celui qui appelle
massif du Tanneron il assiste indépard
de feu sur le bord de l'autoroute alors
je vous invite à une session speaking
connexion en cours
c'est en communication avec le 10/06 le
pompier pilote le téléphone du député
donc il y a par exemple de la fumée
là-bas avec ça je vous montre ce qu'il
en est
un bel outil parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que tout le monde a un smartphone
bon la couverture numérique elle est
censée être bonne partout donc ça veut
dire que vous avez en accès vous avez la
vue quoi dans le quart d'heure je dirais
20 30 appels 112 c'est 20 30 personnes
qui vous appellent pour vous donner un
problème d'un moment dans le flux
d'appel 112 on a réussi à avoir un
requérant qui nous a dit
je suis à côté je vois je vois le feu et
grâce à speaking justement on a pu on a
pu voir le front de flamme qui montait
de suite trois gîtes d'intervention
les Alpes-Maritimes restent une
exception les autres départements à
risque ne disposent pas d'autant de
moyens pour s'adapter aux incendies le
député va devoir convaincre l'assemblée
et pas seulement alors maintenant il
faut
sensibiliser le ministre Gérald Darmanin
qui est je sais qu'il travaille déjà sur
ces sujets
lui montrer ce qu'on arrive à faire en
termes de d'intervention massive et
immédiate et puis aussi apporter des
solutions éventuellement de financement
moi je pense notamment à l'exonération
de la TICPE que paie aujourd'hui les
pompiers les 10 alors qu'elle est pas
payée pour les armées ce qui génèrerait
des des marges budgétaires je pense
aussi à l'exonération du malus
écologique sur lequel les pompiers vont
être je pense aussi à la taxe sur les
assurances qui aujourd'hui est pas
totalement fléchés sur les 10 donc on a
quand même un certain nombre de pistes
sur lesquels on pourrait travailler qui
pourrait permettre de dégager des moyens
dans son rapport le député va aussi
inciter à la prévention avec des
initiatives citoyennes comme les comités
communaux de feux de forêt
le Comité Communal des feux de forêt de
Caussols nous amène voir le dispositif
qu'ils ont mis en place à titre bénévole
de vigie quelque part de l'ensemble de
leur plateau qui leur permet donc de
repérer les départs de feu les fumées
éventuelles
ici dans ce village de l'arrière pays 25
habitants se sont portés volontaires
pour patrouiller pendant la période à
risque
donc de part de par la complexité
géographique du plateau la difficulté
pour nous c'est de repérer les gens de
façon à intervenir très rapidement qu'on
a en général trois patrons sur site par
soirée mais en même temps dans le même
créneau dans le même créneau dans le
même prénom une patrouille c'est minimum
2 voire 3 on a deux observateurs type
vigie qui sont là apost fixe et qui nous
donne par radio les informations qui
nous sont nécessaires pour faire
l'intervention quand on voit des
personnes qui partent par exemple sur le
clapier de femme morte le soir avec des
tentes des sacs à dos on comprend que
c'est des gens qui vont passer la nuit
là donc notre souci c'est que ces gens
en général souvent vont faire un feu et
évidemment le problème c'est d'éviter
tout le départ de feu effectivement
je pense qu'il est à contrôler
à très bien nous y allons de ce pas
camping-car à contrôler parking des GAC
[Musique]
nous faisons partie du comité des feux
de forêt de Caussol donc nous
intervenons
avec des gens qui venaient bivouacle
j'imagine que vous avez passé la nuit
ici c'est exactement donc on est là pour
vous avertir de de laisser propre
l'endroit bien sûr de pas faire de feu à
savoir que vous êtes sur des propriétés
privées à 100% d'accord donc de laisser
l'endroit propre de faire en sorte de
d'être respectueux du site couvrez-vous
quand même parce que la nuit va être
fraîche à mon avis
je vous en prie au plaisir au revoir
monsieur
depuis le début de l'été ils ont fait
éteindre 26 feux en plein cœur de ce
parc naturel régional moi je trouve que
en plus de l'intérêt en termes de
prévention des feux et des incendies et
d'éviter qu'il y a une catastrophe c'est
aussi un moyen de passer le message à
des personnes mal intentionnées que
cette commune est surveillée elle est
sous contrôle par sa population et donc
c'est un moyen dissuasif d'éviter un
autre aspect des incendies qui sont les
pyromanes et les actes criminels
combat d'Éric Poget c'est la lutte
contre la pyromanie agir sur l'origine
du feu
ce jour-là il retrouve le maire de Biot
merci de m'accueillir
fin juillet ils ont connu cette départ
de feu en moins d'une semaine en 30 et
biote
alors là on aperçoit
quelques traces
d'un des départs
et une dizaine de mètres plus loin
entre départ de feu
[Musique]
donc voilà c'est incendie il est là et
regardez tout en bas vous voyez les
maisons il y a plein d'habitations tout
en bas là
voilà des 7 incendies Eric c'est celui
au
plus important et regarde les maisons ah
on voit que c'est carrément à côté il y
a l'intervention de
trois hélicoptères
qui ont permis de stopper cette incendie
très rapidement et les pompiers ont mis
beaucoup de moyens
trois départs de feu sur un secteur d'un
hectare en 48 heures ça peut être que
criminel
[Musique]
le député alourdir les sanctions que des
peines de prison soient systématiquement
prononcé contre les pyromanes et que les
récidivistes soient condamnés à de la
prison ferme
dans le temps si on sait que
l'acte de pyromanie est sévèrement puni
et que le système judiciaire derrière
quelque part contraint et c'est pas
politiquement correct ce que je dis dans
la sanction qui va prononcer oui en tout
cas ça sera une prise de conscience
parce que le sujet sur lequel il faut
qu'on lutte à mes yeux c'est de penser
que ce n'est uniquement que le
dérèglement climatique le réchauffement
climatique ou des conditions climatiques
anormales qui font qu'il y a des
incendies ça y contribue ça développe le
feu mais à la base c'est un acte humain
et c'est un acte humain criminel et
c'est de ça dans la société a besoin de
se prémunir
la main de l'homme est à l'origine de
presque tous les feux de forêt par
accident ou intentionnellement cet été
en France 48 personnes soupçonnées
d'avoir volontairement allumé des feux
ont été interpellés
[Musique]